[Música]
a lei
eu tenho que começas atendendo a um
pedido do jornal diário tem como
explicar o que qual foi a minha reação
quando eu me convidaram pra ver quanto e
dex as pessoas dos 10 anos continua lec
na verdade o robô é então aqui há 15
anos atrás
acho que cinco estavam organizar um
evento aqui em mana e eu fiquei
entusiasmada porque já tinha visto uma
estátua toque na net então foi tipo
quando a luzia nos anos 90 quando
voltava nós do tipo time estava um jeito
ea fã mesmo assim então fiz a
application e foi preenchendo aquino
feliz com meu ex-marido na altura e
quando chegou o momento de escrever o
que eu fazia eu disse que era professora
de yoga e é engenheiro químico gestor de
projetos
o parente foi aceite ou não então este
ano vieram ter comigo a pedir para ser
oradora ó hoje já não vai estudar essa
prova viva que um não não é nada me
programo só vamos seguir em frente mas
eu estou aqui para vos falar de uma
atração deve se perguntar você já se
perguntaram por que tantas cesarianas
porque tantas mães sem conseguirem da
peito aos seus filhos porque tanto a
depressão pós parto porque tantas
doenças como asma diabetes doença
celíaca doenças cardiovasculares
alergias kansas
já tentaram a imaginar um mundo de
opções saudáveis de mais satisfeitas com
seus partos satisfeitos por poderem dar
o peito aos seus filhos
de seus humanos saudáveis produtivos
para uma economia estável com direito à
habitação à educação acesso à saúde
a boa alimentação já tentaram imaginar
um mundo de família sem serem
estabilizados pelas tão mal entendidas e
não diagnosticadas depressões pós parte
é eu quero vos convidar a fazer uma
viagem pelas maternidades e clínicas
neste mundo quando uma mulher entra em
trabalho de parto ela é aconselhada pelo
seu médico aí para o hospital
ora bem ela podia ficar em casa mais
algum tempo até o seu trabalho parte
está estabelecido no conforto da sua
casa que o seu ninho com a sua família
com seu marido a com chegada mas a gente
tem medo do que possa acontecer e também
a família faz pressão então a gente vai
para o hospital
os hospitais têm um protocolo chamado
gestão ativa de parte
nesse protocolo dentre outras regras os
médicos da equipa médica deve fazer tudo
ao seu alcance tomar todas as medidas
necessárias para que o bebê nasça dentro
do tempo estipulado pelo protocolo 12
horas
isto é o quarto não correr de forma
apropriada
se a mulher não estiver a delatar um
centímetro por hora depois dos três
centímetros de dilatação
a equipa médica deve fazer intervenções
médicas para que ela tenha o quarto mais
assegurado
então essa equipa médica vai entrar e
vai compor uma piscina para a sociedade
o parque que é a mesma medicação
utilizada para induzir em 12 partes bem
quando o trabalho do partido começa
naturalmente o que acontece
os níveis altos de progesterona que
manteve durante toda a gravidez
no fim no fim da gravidez que eu não
devia ter dito isto mas jô
depois de pôr um fim são ultrapassados
pelos níveis de estrogênio que sobem com
os níveis de dioxina cidade pelo bb
os níveis de ocitocina conversa gravada
fazem com que os níveis de estrogênio da
mãe subam e esses níveis de estrogênio
ultrapassam os níveis de progesterona
edital final da gravidez
os níveis de dioxina não só fazem com
que o nível de estrogênio dor da mãe sul
mas também são captados pelo fã desse
pelo topo do colo do útero que têm
receptores da oxitocina
então quando eles são captados pelo topo
do colo do útero o topo do colo do útero
começa às contrações que empurrou para
baixo quando bebê empurrado para baixo
faz pressão sobre o colo do útero que
manda uma mensagem para o cérebro para
produzir mais a situação o cérebro
produz mais aceito a sina que é recebida
pelo topo do colo do útero que empurra o
bebê para baixo que faz pressão sobre o
colo do outro e assim progride
o partido então num hospital
ela chega e é exibida por uma equipa
médica gente desconhecida tá no ambiente
frio como luz muito fortes a conjunta
passar de um lado para hoje desconhecida
olhar ea tocar nas partes mais íntimas
dela e ela tem um tempo para ter esse
bem o que é completamente contrário ao
que uma mulher na verdade precisa para a
parede
a mulher precisa de aconchego e carinho
de baixas de intimidade e privacidade a
precisa de sentir segura em nesse
momento ela não está sendo e segura ela
faça sentir intimidada e ela em história
sobre garotos citocina ela taça bh
adrenalina que faço parte fica mais
lento e até pode parar o partido por
dias ou semanas
então porque conceito assina é super
importante
a ocitocina é importante porque ela é na
verdade
a moça ela é obra homônima responsável
por todas as sensações de prazer pelos
orgasmos por nos apaixonarmos por uma
pessoa e por aquela sensação de namur
aumento que nós temos pelos nossos
filhos quando eles nascem quando a gente
recebe pinto assina que nos é dada para
acelerar o parto quando estamos a
segregar a adrenalina porque estamos com
medo daquela situação em que estamos no
hospital
a oxfam se na barra a segrega apitoxina
perdão barra a segregação da citocina
normal da mulher
então isto quer dizer que aquela chance
dela se apaixonar pelo bebê dela no
primeiro momento começa a ser diminuída
começa a desvanecer então apitoxina
nunca poderá substituir a oxitocina
normal natural das mulheres porque ela
não passa a barreira cerebral ela atua
única e exclusivamente sobre o músculo
treino quando a mulher lá estar com
apito assim não para acelerar o parto
ela começa a sentir contrações muito
muito muito mais forte do que as
naturais então num curto espaço de tempo
ela vai pedir por uma epidural porque
quem aguenta tanto a 2
então ela pega a epidural ainda não está
com a delegação completa da epidural das
a epidural a epidural por sua vez atrasa
desacelera o processo do partido
aí os médicos tempo mais pinto assina
para assegurar parte mais pinto assina
com traços mais fortes ainda elas não
para sentir as contrações tão forte que
está com a equipe brawn mas as contas
tão forte para o bebê
então o que acontece o ritmo cardíaco do
bebê normal durante o trabalho de parto
é estável entre contratações e diminui
durante as contrações com as contrações
naturais ele diminuir ligeiramente com
contrações cada vez mais fortes vai
diminuindo mais e mais e mais e mais
o que quer dizer
que quando o ritmo cardíaco baixa demais
o bebê entra em risco de entrar em
sofrimento se manter esse padrão
isso acontece muito frequentemente os
bebés entram em sofrimento
a mulher ainda não tenha lotação
completa
e quando isso acontece tem que extrair o
bb o mais rapidamente possível qual a
forma mais rápida de extrair um bebê
cesariana
até então não vai a mulher a correr pro
bloco operatório a pensar que o seu
corpo falhou que seu colo do útero não
abriu é incompetentes que ela teve uma
falha no parque falha do programa no
parte como um hedge tenha notificado
pelos médicos e ao mesmo tempo ela vai
pensando fogo graças a deus que está
aqui esse equipamento é capaz de salvar
a minha e salvar o meu filho desse meu
corpo foi inconstante
ela vai e faz a cesariana e tem um filho
mas quando ela tenha um filho ela perde
o vínculo a conexão que foi feita com
esse filho durante toda a gravidez ela
sente se culpada ela julga se ela sente
que ela falhou essa criança no primeiro
momento dessa criança e isto é
extremamente traumatizantes para todas
todas as mães para o momento do parto é
uma coisa que nos fica para toda a vida
então isso acaba por nos causar traumas
mas lá vamos lá passamos por isso e eu
pessoalmente passei por uma situação
muito parecida que foi estágio na mesa
de operações sem nenhuma hormona minha
há a fazer o seu papel porque não entrei
em trabalho de parto
eu fui como muitas mulheres vão para uma
cesariana marcada porque tinha sim uma
condição que precisava de uma cesariana
marcada mas pronto podia ter digerido a
forma da o problema de outra forma
fui no parto foi feito
nenhuma situação na minha quando meu
filho nasceu não senti nem a alegria em
tristeza nem noção nem paixão nem amor
nada estava completamente congelada
completamente bloqueada ea única coisa
que eu fazia era culpa mim mesma o tempo
todo por não estar ali para o meu filho
por não ter ouvido os meus instintos
porque quando nós estávamos no quarto à
espera que eu fosse pro bloco operatório
eu tenho o o o monitor fetal na barriga
eo meu filho não parava de lutar contra
ele mas inicialmente não parava de lutar
e eu ouvia na minha cabeça mas não está
pronto mas não estou pronto obama notou
pront e não estava ele achou com os
pulmões prematuras e teve que ir pra
unidade neonatal de cuidados intensivos
e aí mais ainda o nosso vínculo foi
quebrado e era uma criança com quem eu
tinha feito uma conexão tão especial
durante a gravidez toda uma coisa linda
em cima mas aí o nosso vínculo foi
cobrado e eu pensei que eu já não era
mãe que eu não sabia como semana em que
eu não era apropriada para ser mãe e eu
acho que eu partilho desse de
sentimentos com muitas outras mulheres
o que se seguiu depois foram quase dois
anos da depressão pós parto não
diagnosticada mal entendida pela família
com muitos episódios de choro de
desespero e que podem crer que o fizeram
pensar em acabar com a minha vida ou
fazer alguma ao meu filho
isso não foi um filho que não foi
planeado foi planeado e lutado através
de uma fertilização em vitro
portanto quando a gente pois olha para
estas situações desta forma não é assim
tão difícil de entender as mães que nos
não se sinta em mães as mães que cometem
suicídio logo depois seus filhos
nascerem as mães que abandonam os seus
filhos
é mais fácil a gente ser um caminho mais
humano e
vender estas estas situações e os as
conseqüências deste protocolo não possam
só pela experiência pessoal dessa mãe
dessa criança ou dessa família
elas marcam nos a todos como sociedade
porque quando o bebê nasce no ambiente
hospitalar
ele nasce fora do seu habitat natural
que a sua casa
nós todos devemos mexer na nossa casa
porque é porque quando estamos na nossa
casa nós somos automaticamente
colonizados pelas bactérias da nossa
casa e vamos conferir imunidades para as
doenças do meio em que nós vivemos com
libertinagem por cesariana anos também
são roubados das primeiras vacinas que
os apanhou na verdade que são passadas
de mãe para filho pelo canal vaginal
todas as bactérias que a mãe tem no
canal vaginal cobra essa criança
completamente economizam na estudares as
primeiras vacinas a primeira imunidade
para a asma diabete doença celíaca
câncer e doenças cardiovasculares
então o que acontece com este protocolo
e esta epidemia de cesarianas que não
estamos a viver hoje em dia é que já
temos vindo a viver há algum tempo algum
tempo pra cá espalhou se pelo mundo e
fez com que neste momento nós tivesse
uns adultos pouco saudáveis adultos
pouco produtivos para uma economia e
isso nós não foram de proativos para nós
próprios fazermos escolhas
nós vamos informar mais sobre os
processos do parto sobre com as
medicações nos afetam e o que se pode
fazer alternativamente a receber essas
medicações faz com que mais e mais e
mais e mais bebés nasçam sem imunidade
com uma saúde minuto ida isto vai criar
um mundo completo adultos com pouca
saúde e que vai ter que gastar bastante
dinheiro
quero para os tratamentos de saúde
destes adultos está estipulado que em
vão ser gastos 47 trilhões de dólares só
para tratamentos médicos por estas
doenças
quando a coisa podia ser muito bem
enfeitada no momento do parto os médicos
estão bastante cientes destes protocolos
deste protocolo a uma outra forma de
gerir o parto que a gestão expectantes
que alguns médicos utilizam mas que é
muito mais utilizada pelas parteiras e
pelos profissionais do parto humanizado
que é deixar as coisas acontecerem
esperar pra ver tomar medidas e
intervenções única e exclusivamente
quando for estritamente necessário
hoje em dia a gente abusa das
intervenções fazem intervenções por tudo
e por nada a gente diz a mulher pode
fazer uma indução ea mulher sequer sabe
quais são as consequências dessas
reduções e esse é o meu trabalho como
duba explicar as mulheres tudo isso as
mulheres não são as mulheres aos homens
também a família toda
todas as opções que elas têm durante a
gravidez para seu trabalho para o seu
poste parte da arte toda a educação
necessária para esse momento para que as
pessoas possam estar enquadrados e
fazerem as escolhas corretas e poderem
debater de igual para igual com seus
médicos as suas opções
então quando eu olho para isso tudo
quando olho para minha experiência
quando eu olho para o mundo que eu quero
ver que é o mundo em que as mulheres
voltam a confiar na sua capacidade de
paris num mundo em que as mulheres são
respeitadas que o tempo do parto dela é
respeitado no mundo em que a gente tem
noção do que aquilo que a gente faz a
mãe afeta diretamente o bebê um mundo de
famílias mais estáveis mais equilibradas
demais mais feliz mais satisfeitas com
seu parto porque todos nós podemos ter
um bom momento do parto isso é verdade
podemos passar por um situações
inesperadas sim mas todos nós podemos
ter um bom momento do parto e é isso que
nós temos estado a esquecer porque nós
vivemos um momento do parto como muito
muito aterrorizante hoje em dia mas eu
vejo realmente um mundo de opções mais
saudáveis
a produzirem para uma economia mais
estava e um mundo em que nós temos toda
a informação necessária para fazer as
nossas escolhas para nós protegeremos
nos a nós e aos nossos filhos
as nossas famílias e no fundo ao nosso
mundo o nosso planeta nossa sociedade no
futuro
michel o dantes um obstetra francês que
é muito muito pelo parto humanizado
costuma dizer que para mudar o mundo nós
temos primeiro que mudar a forma de
prancheta e é nisso que eu acredito é
com isso que eu trabalho mudar a forma
da chesf
[Aplausos]